see boys Smiley man my new tape out
right now I did what I did make sure you
guys check that out and check me on
bootleg cabs new podcast coming sorry
[__] it's fine it's
it's starting with these things it's
starting right now Smiley the podcast is
starting right now
who like cat podcast special guest
Smiley is here yes sir glad to be here
in the building oh my God thank you for
having me you know you have uh quietly
one of the more influential flows of the
last few years yes yes yes growing it's
growing I won't be surprised when it's
up there I'ma be honest with you when I
first heard your song with Drake right
first time I ever heard you
my wife was so tired of me playing this
song we were on vacation like two or
three years ago that was like two years
ago we were in Florida
and the song I just can't I just your
flow it was like I thought you were gay
though
I've seen all those comments The Sassy
show I was like this boy's sassy as [__]
I don't I don't know how Sassy why I
understand it like because you were like
yeah yeah yeah I understand the comments
like you know I've seen all those
comments and show like but but yeah man
I mean I've heard so many artists like
you know take your flow on songs at
times yeah yeah yeah you know there's
like a
did you uh like like I'll I think shout
out to be because be a kind of did your
flow on that song London yeah yeah shout
out to be uh did she tap in with you
yeah yeah she for sure no she's like a
real one for sure yeah yeah so Bo is
actually one of the first industry
people that actually showed love to me
she's great like you know she
she tapped in from way back then yeah
she's OG people don't know she's been
doing today for years yeah yeah super
focused so you're originally from the
Toronto area yeah yeah Toronto Canada
you guys are out there uh taking chains
and stuff what's going on oh [__] yeah I
don't know what's going on it's a little
rough out there huh
rough draft because we hear like it's
you know it's like Canadians are so
polite yeah at least you know when we
think of like the stereotypical Canadian
as an American I think of like polite
dudes you know Drake's a sweetheart
Justin Bieber
you know like uh there's Canadian bacon
you know uh you guys get free healthcare
and then you guys also Rob people when
that don't happen everywhere has its bad
places you know so it's like right I
don't know why people think that they
just think Toronto is just all are the
sexy girls in the world ah I keep
hearing that I keep hearing it's like
just like you go to Toronto and you're
like oh the most beautiful people in the
world live here yeah I hear that all the
time I'm like [__] I guess what area are
you from
um Highland Park Gardens like the west
side of the city okay so sketch area do
you have a good upbringing like a sketch
area for sure but
it's mostly like
it's not like that area is more like
drug trafficking than it is like
like art might get like our people
we're just like
not until the Aurora stuff like it was
just mostly making money you know making
money keeping it and if it has to be
like that it's like that but like no we
just make money over there there's
enough money for all of us trap boys
[__] real trap boys because the fentanyl
hit Canada yet oh for sure fennels
everywhere crazy man I'm so glad I like
I never tried it like I never got in any
hard drugs
but anytime I tried any drugs it was
prior to there being fentanyl you know
so it's like now I just eat shrooms
people always tell me [__] you'll
have a good a good [__] high you know
like you won't trip all the schumers are
always say you won't trip but that out
the non-shoomers side is like yo I had a
bad trip I won't ever do it again cause
they're [__] [__] yo no but I don't
have a [__] up trip have you ever had
shrooms no really I tried once like the
chocolate bar shop well I don't think
they're inconsistent yeah I don't think
I took enough for me to feel anything so
like you got to go in man you got to go
just peel back the layers of reality I
feel like I'll just hi you might cry
yourself in a corner like like in a
fetal position but it'll be you'll be
better for it I'm more of a adderall
type of guy so you like to be a
tentative
I like to like you know I want to be in
the studio for 20 hours yeah I heard
Adderall if you ever want to like edit a
music video in an hour yeah yeah
especially if I know like I'm up this
whole time and I want to stay up even
longer yeah it's meth yeah
right now I'm I've been sober for a
month good for you hey cold turkey I've
been cold turkey when I go sober I cold
turkey everything I just wake up one day
and say I want to go turkey [__] and
yeah I have a happy that I'm one month
in right now so so you had like a were
you dependent on the Adderall because I
know a lot of my friends who like are
Engineers yeah like for sure when I'm
drinking and all that stuff and I need
when I I drink too a lot so like I'm
meshing them together it's making me
drink even more than normally so and I'm
staying up longer so it's like yeah [__]
it I was depending on it for sure and
yeah right now I'm not you know what's
the longest you stayed up
like two days specifically yeah yeah
yeah
yeah not good for you I'm sure not not
good at all don't do that please was it
a productive two days at least yeah
super productive that's one thing I will
say like when I do drink and all these
things it's not just for fun and games I
I do it for Creative to be more creative
if I'm in a stuck place like you know
that's why I do it but for sure I've got
so much good things out of it like ideas
even talks of my teams like I'll be
it'll be more productive on my side you
know so I don't do it for just fun and
games realistically so I just found out
that you're half Mexican yes yes
Mexicano
why did I just find this out you got to
be waving that flag bro I know I know I
know y'all know why oh peso pluma is
done you know y'all know why though
because I don't know Spanish who cares I
know I know but I feel like I want to
get more with the culture first I don't
think do you know who oh Jeezy is yeah I
have a song and a shout out great guy
I'm 90 sure he doesn't know Spanish
but he looks super due with the culture
you look more Mexican than oh Jeezy
am I lying
oh Jeezy looks like if you told me oh
Jeezy was like like Italian I'd be like
yeah I see it oh yeah I could see the
you know the time but since I now know
you're mad I'm like yeah of course he is
I mean yeah it makes sense you know what
is your other half Keisha Haitian and
Mexican that's a great uh that's a very
uncommon mixture of human in the United
States
and I speak French French is actually my
first language
so yeah yeah I went to like a whole
French school to like grade 10. and then
I went to English school for like two
months and got expelled so you you like
grew up speaking French yeah yeah yeah
like my mom every yeah I was grew up
speaking French but the English also but
French was my first language wow which
side of your uh family is it your mom
your dad's side that's Mexican Mom Mom's
Mexican is she put you on at all no not
really because she was actually adopted
oh okay so she's not that's why I'm not
right because like she's not tapped in
like that she doesn't know Spanish
herself she knows a [__] she
understands but she doesn't know
yeah you see I don't know yeah a little
bit so she was adopted by
um France like her mom's from France
okay so I have like a whole next family
side and Paris the adopted side yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I'm super tapped in
with them also too like when I go to
yeah I go to Paris a lot too visit your
family yeah
um
my wife is Mexican and my kids are
Mexican so I know probably more Spanish
yeah [__] man I'm gonna get a tutor soon
I need a nice Mamacita
have you been to Mexico yeah once which
part Mexico City beautiful yeah yeah
only once but I
that's the only I want to go back you
know yeah I need to type in you gotta
you need to help me type in this whole
demographic yeah yeah do you know who MC
Magic is wow yeah but Rob not bad I'm
bad Vicente Fernandez
oh [__] Tigres del Norte no one you know
who peso Puma is all right no like I
heard all these names but like um peso
plume is like the biggest artist in the
world right now he's like a Mexican Bad
Bunny bro he's crazy you gotta tap in
you got the wrapper bro I'll tap in with
them for sure would you say his name is
again peso Puma peso Puma uh he's
actually I think he's half Lebanese half
Mexican but he's fire
but he's thinking like real traditional
you know yeah I'm gonna tap in after
this I'm gonna listen to some show so
are you still on OVO yeah yeah yeah yeah
for you like uh I just saw Drake shout
you out in this interview where he's
with this random white woman in bed
Bobby shut up Bobby
do we know where this girl came from
you know how they say there's industry
plants in hip-hop I feel like she's like
an industry playing on the media side
because I'm like where did this girl
come from so you never see interviews
I've only seen the funny Marco one oh it
was like it was funny Margo and then it
was Drake and I was like that escalated
quickly like shout out to her yeah
that's did she follow you no no no she
didn't she did I guess she wasn't
interested
try to set you up a lot no no no no no
no no no
gotta stop the interview to say about
our good Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah
shout out to odd talks now this is what
I love about Odd Socks one their family
we love them but also they have the most
comfortable socks in the [__] world
all right now look they got the craziest
licenses you see the Jolly Rancher these
are actually flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the Odd Socks Basics now
these are just the basic socks so these
are in my bag because I'm taking these
I love these Odd Socks basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview
um are you are you living in the US you
live in Canada are you splitting time or
what are you doing split in time
especially because right now I just
dropped my tape I did what I did oh no
go stream that but I live in Toronto
mostly right because my daughter is over
there also
so like I just try to split the time
equally
like how's your daughter she's five oh
you got a little kindergartener back
yeah yeah yeah she's in Camp right now
enjoying her Camp time yeah yeah summer
camp and I just when I was there I was
dropping in an account every day and
then oh every time I drop her to these
things like the the cat people are so
excited to see me you know they're like
smiling yeah so she gets this different
type of she probably gets better
treatment yeah extra snacks at lunch
yeah you've been like at school
sometimes sometimes I don't think she
likes it too because I don't think she
likes she wants all the attention too
she's a little star girl too so like you
know is she aware that you're famous
yeah yeah yeah she's super aware does
she have a favorite Smiley song
um not really to be honest like she'll
sing them like she doesn't really like
I serve too much in it in my songs too
so I don't really played around her or
anything like that and like I don't
really play my music earlier so like I
and like when she hears my music
sometimes she'll be like that you're
swearing this this like I try not to
swear as much but like yeah
um where would you say like oh first of
all how long like did you start rapping
like how long has it been since you kind
of first started taking this serious so
probably like
seven years ago but that was when I
first started rapping and I was in a
group of three people it was three of us
and I was like I always say that's why
it's just funny because I was like the
least favorite in the group was because
I didn't rap they forced me to get on
the song Because I set up the studio
session for them because I'm like yo you
guys after I got expelled from the
English school in two months of being
there I'm like yo you guys are sick like
you guys keep freestyling the hood and I
see the potential in them I set up a
studio session and then they went they
did their first song yeah and I'm like
[__] I never even wrapped a day in my
life I don't know how to do Alvin know
any flaws nothing I did my first song
and that's how my flow came about was it
nothing I thought of nothing it was this
is your first song you automatically
yeah I said it I didn't premeditated
nothing you know so
yeah that was my first song and then
from there we had we gained a little
traction and then we just kept going
dropping a song probably every three
months and then we all got arrested
together in a read and now we became
cool cues so that we couldn't make music
together so then where you became more
cool cues were like when let's say me
and you we got arrested you guys aren't
allowed to legally hang out yeah yeah
none of that we're on house for us and
then they stopped making music and I'm
like [__] up like my solo yeah I'm
like yo you guys are done and we can't
make music together someday imma just
try a thing like you know I'm gonna make
my songs by myself and I recorded videos
in my in my backyard yeah and I kept
going and then from there I had a I
stopped for a bit and then
I just decided to go serious at some
point in time you know what you guys get
rated for
um Trap House you know chop was a
running yeah booming
make that [__] boom brother what do you
do you remember when you first like uh
found out Drake knew who you were yeah
so the first time was
I'm just there chilling in my house
I see someone sends me a
a a
DM like yo look at this my phone starts
going crazy says Smiley Drake comments
under one of his boys
um Instagram post that he posted one of
my videos and that was us in the group
also we did like a group song and then
he commented Smiley equals gold and then
at that time I didn't even know what
gold meant right I'm like okay like why
is he call me a girl I'm like you know
what no wait this to me and like I was
literally a fan of him like from before
I knew he knew who I was type of [__] I
mean he's Drake yeah no but like at
those times
the hood guys and stuff like weren't
listening like I was still bumping him
like that like you know like we're
listening to Drake there would be like
they were listening yes they were but
they're they were doing silent like yeah
like quietly yeah like you know I was
bumping that [__] so then when that
happened I'm like holy then I asked my
sister she was beside me and then she's
just like she tells me what it means I
know [__] it wait the greatest of all
time so I was I was stunned surprised
and then I just my Instagram started
flooding crazy and then that that was
motivation right there also you know so
but I felt like I manifested that also
well how'd you manifest it because
there's always excessively playing his
songs just [__] really feeling his
songs like I feel like I've manifest
things and that was another thing I
manifested what's your favorite album of
his
my favorite album it's not I wouldn't
say I was always this song songs and
moments I just became right now
listening to people's full albums I
never used it used to be this the
playlist guy the song yeah like and I
would listen to one song 800 times like
yeah right but not the whole body of
work yeah so I used to be that right now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so Drake owes me fifty thousand
dollars so if we can get him
oh why why do you see that what is he
always we made a bet together I I met
him in a place called Harriet's in West
Hollywood oh yeah Harriet he was up at
the Harriet's bar
and me and Freddie Gibbs were chopping
it up when it was the first time I ever
met him and we get into this basketball
discussion
and he bet me fifty thousand dollars
that the warriors were going to go
further than my sons in the playoffs
and uh we agreed to the BET multiple
Witnesses including Freddie Gibbs uh and
the Suns went to the finals
and now I can't get a hold of Drake
[Laughter]
holy [__] you have to go see him at that
did you see his uh his freestyles the
one on the radar freestyle with the
potential seems crazy he's pissed off is
he moving like that I don't know yo it's
like he's got like a battery in his back
so he's showing a little sample off the
new the new album have you heard the new
album no no I haven't heard it hey let's
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our good Folks at King Palm
that's right man shout out to King Palm
uh we're talking about nothing but that
organic all right that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg have try either one of those
I forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discreetly of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right blueshoe.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview
um who's on your project
um solo straight solo yeah yeah I like
that yeah yeah just trying to
because for me I want my next hit to
just be by myself
it'll mean more to me you know Smiley
featuring smiley yeah yeah yeah cause I
that would mean a lot to me and then
yeah that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
manifest it you guys will see it and
you'll play this clip again listen we
got to get you a song with peso Puma man
it has to happen we have to let's do it
we gotta take you to Mexico you gotta do
a tour out there we got to take you to
Tijuana yeah I mean
TJ's a movie you know yeah I'm a fish
shirts happen about his music after this
I was gonna say like uh for you
talk to me about your ad-libs because
you have some great ad-libs okay so at
first like when I first started
what I did late me for at the beginning
was my ad-libs so I'm like oh I'm an I
live guy yeah all right so now I know I
have to just spice it up on the ad-libs
you know so then
[__] I just
now that I overthink it sometimes they
don't hit the same stuff try not to
overthink it you know but it's so funny
now nowadays when I record I don't
really care for the ad-libs most of the
songs I've only been do add up somewhere
until I know I'm picking these songs for
a tape and then you go back yeah but
like no I don't before I was
what do you think is your quintessential
signature ad-lib
it has to be like the yeah it's the yeah
huh yeah
but he's like the yeah guys
you know I listened to all the critiques
and I I take it in you know so like now
I try to say that yeah in a different
way about say it the way you're saying
it bro sometimes I try to change it up
because I like to take the critiques you
know I think it's dope about you is you
very original in a world full of
unoriginality yeah so I enjoy it for
sure yeah appreciate the 100 man um so
the tape's out right now anything else
coming the rest of the year what are you
doing a next tip by the end of the year
um while I'm still working on my album
and about to just tour and do a bunch of
tourists stuff yeah like I'm setting up
something right now so I announce it
soon and I'm just working on music you
know just trying to get better and
better obviously you're huge in Canada
right in the US you have a market what
is that other Market outside of Canada
in the US that you're living is it Paris
is it the UK
um where
uh Australia Australia yeah
never have a little fan base going on
over there Germany also France
my song was just in Shazam I was
noticing a a little [__] Trend
traction yeah and Shazam people are
Shazam in my song so yeah that's sick
but yeah just more music coming and
yeah I'm just trying to motivate the
people I'm trying to go four months
sober right now if I do that I'll be my
biggest record
my last record was who wants sober one
that's just off is that off a liquor and
Adderall everything I know cold turkey
and like from my first record I was at
nicotine guy when I did my first you
were smoking cigarettes no I wasn't
doing that so that wasn't part of
addiction now when I did it I was a
vapor I smoked cigarettes so now I'm
cold turkey extra thing you know so
you're not doing vaping anymore nothing
yeah I feel like that's not sober if I
don't do everything yeah The Vaping is
also probably like uh worse for you than
yeah than weed super were you a smoker
super bad no I'm more not more than
uppers more more alcohol than weed weed
anxiety level [__] out the roof yeah
four months sober yeah yeah I think it's
about a year or sober and you know
what's so crazy no a year I'll go four
months first but like
my birthday is coming out August 6th so
and right now I'm planning to just go do
that sober also it's a tough day to get
through sober and it's it's better if I
do it this time right now because it's
the hardest time to be sober which is
Summer right summertime so if I get to
it yeah and then I'll know I'll be good
for the rest of the year and you got the
album out so it's not like you got to be
like super you know you don't got to
record which I'm sure recording no I
still recording I I canceled my release
party to bring it in the studio because
two reasons I want to obviously make
more music and I'm like why am I gonna
have a release party if I'm not gonna
really enjoy it and turn up you know I'd
rather just do it in the studio and
yeah like you know because I'm like the
thing is with being sober is
I like to leave I could go to a party
still and not drink but I like to leave
when I want to leave if it's my own
party I can't leave oh it's the worst I
have to [__] stay and go [__] guy
yeah
they call the Irish goodbye we're like
you'll just be gone and never be like yo
what happened to smiley smiley yeah did
he say bye yeah sometimes I might be in
the bathroom I'll calculating my head
I'll be like [__] should I say bye to
everyone like no there's 20 people out
this [__] you gotta answer it no just
get the [__] out yeah do the Irish boys
get that Irish goodbye bro
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and then
just never come back
sometimes too much good was oh I
appreciate you following through man I
appreciate you for having me your new
tapes out yes yes yes go run it up more
new music on the way tour coming soon
yes sir Smiley gang boom
hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the hardeen family in Las
Vegas make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you could ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow them and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon